how we feeling about uh the Raptors you
feeling good about the uh Scotty Barnes
is balling you rapor yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but you know what I haven't even
been paying attention to no sports like
not even football this year for some
reason are you I know you you play
football yeah yeah I coach now a little
bit too you know what I'm saying but
like but I used to I used to play are we
talking about soccer or football no
American football I got to ask cuz
you're from a different country and I
know inot everywhere else footb football
too we got we got to leave no one
watches the CFL I watch it man I'm
Canadian you know Canadians we watch
itre le they have the NFL on in Canada
of course we do yeah we got the NFL yeah
I don't know yeah we got we got we watch
we got everything we got everything so
you play football what like tackle
football yeah yeah tackle football but
in in Canada we don't have four downs we
have three Downs it's weird really yeah
and our football is like bigger way it's
like it's different so you have a bigger
ball yeah a bigger football field as
well it's like 120 yards yeah it's crazy
the end Zone's huge man it's like back
in the day 1950 stle football wait is
that how the CFL is yeah yeah go search
up type in CFL highlights whatever
you'll see how big the field giant ball
yeah it's big bro so you're like you
have pads on and a helmet and [__]
everything yeah number 80 yeah are you a
wide receiver yeah I was a wide receiver
and a a safety and a punter but mainly
receiver yeah punting kicking yeah
punting catching and defending and yeah
yeah I'm the I'm the the Deep help what
got you in the football my Dad Dad the
football guy yeah when he moved to
Guyana from Guyana to Canada MH uh the
first um football game he ever seen was
the Chicago Bears I think it was when
the year that won the Super Bowl the 85
Bears yeah and you know he just fell in
love with the Bears so he's a Bears fan
he's a bear yeah he's a Bears fan I'm a
Steelers fan yeah so you're a Steelers
fan yeah I'm a Steelers fan for that
what gravitated you towards the Steelers
I don't know I used to play I used to
play Madden all the time and I used to
watch the game sometimes and I was just
like y I just love the way they play
football no no this is back Jerome
Bettis and Cordell Stewart Cordell was a
beast yeah when Plaxico was on the team
bur Ward
yeah I mean yeah that happened Paul yeah
Troy but Troy wasn't on the team them
times then but so then I remember when I
watched the old five old six Super Bowl
when they play Seahawks that I was like
holy [__] there was a whole new team
right but it was the last game for
Bettis and I watched that and I was like
oh my God this is just it was different
for me when I was a kid so have you been
to a Steelers game in you know I never
been to a steel game I actually want to
do that this tour I want to do that yeah
I want to go I want to go yeah I want to
catch man yeah see Kenny picking and GP
and these guys man yeah hey man I want I
don't know how you guys are six and
three it's the biggest mystery to me you
guys are the luckiest team ever cuz you
guys don't have much talent on trying no
we have talent Harris somehow is washed
in his third year no it's not he's not
watch Jaylen Warren is way better than
Naji Harris oh my God see the outside
criticism is crazy you mean jayen Warren
just had 110 yards in know I na had like
83 I seen how much carries it was
similar na Harris I don't know how he
just fell off
like system I feel like the system that
they're trying to um play in right now
like with Matt Canada it's too all over
the place they don't have a ident as
they said an identity right now you know
are they are you a pass are you a pass
team are you do you pass deep are you
just trying to run first like what are
you guys doing like nobody knows over
there you believe in Kenny picket yeah
he has talent I've seen you believe like
that's your quarterback thisen I believe
he can definitely take us somewhere yes
if he has Yes Man the guy when I seen
him in his rookie when I seen him rookie
season and I seen him making progression
this is the conference that has Joe
burrow Allen Patrick Mahomes Justin
Herbert can he pick it I feel like once
he gets [__] bum no he's not man he
is a homeless man no my God you're the
hate is crazy can he pick it is hor man
the man was making progressions as a
Young quarterback that was like that's
that's insane you just need to there's
so many good things I seen making right
decisions in his rookie year like when
he really started getting the groove I
said yo there's a lot of potential that
they can work work on right here you
know what I'm saying but they have no
the very young offensive line
everybody's so young on that on that
offense K he pick it Mitch Tris are not
that far apart no they are far apart
definitely I feel like they're far apart
come on I feel like you got to give
Kenny I feel like no some some more time
yeah little CH one more year especially
with a different OC and then I'll make
my assumption on how you know what I'm
saying I going to go man I feel like I
feel like they could you rather have
Josh
dos dos is playing really Nicea you
could you could but but he mind you he
was on the Steelers he was and you guys
should have you had he was on the
Steelers then he went to the Browns then
he went to my Cardinals then we tra the
Viking and the Vikings and he's balling
right now crazy I believe in Kenny
though I believe in Kenny you're you're
a sweet guy cuz you're famous and you
know you might meet him one day no I
really believe in Kenny man I watched
the guy play man no I'm not Kenny Kenny
pick it I believe in you I follow bro I
like I see I like what I see man no one
I believe he's going to yeah man I feel
like once he gets in a right situation
once he gets like you know once they F
their identity on offense I feel like we
can see something something really
happen you see fourth quarter Kenny we
all you see him in the fourth quarter
the man's going crazy like he's Brady
over there right you see it come on you
don't he to tell me you're not seeing
the fourth quarter highlights bro you
guys have gotten lucky all season long
there's actually a stat cuz I gamble and
there's like a way they figure out like
the luckiest teams and the over the last
three years the Pittsburgh Steelers have
the the the most they're the most lucky
team of football because of how close
their wins are yeah yeah very close
barely just won 1.3 points yeah we're
winning by those even with Ben though
that's what was going on well cuz Ben
was like a corpse yeah but I mean I feel
like it's really just for like the last
five years of Ben's career he was like
the Joe Biden of quarterbacks like just
waiting for him to like fall break
everybody he was but he was still
slinging it he wasn't the same old Ben
but he was still slinging it shout out
to the Steelers who would have thought
huh yeah man you guys beat my I'm a
Cardinal fan you guys beat us in the
Super Bowl look at that and you have so
much to say [__] the Steelers man I hate
the [__] Steelers I can tell no
wonder no wonder no wonder this energy
is coming so heavy from this side of the
room right now you know think it as a
bum he's not man going to draft somebody
watch man no I feel like he can do
amazing things you just got to give him
some patience get the right offensive
system going on and we'll figure it out
trust me man trust me watch watch watch
yeah you got to go to a game I can't
believe I got through I really got have
you been to a football game yes yes yes
I've been to yeah NFL game my first one
was the Chargers against Patriots last
yeah yeah yeah here oh yeah lost
depressing
huh I like Herbert man I like no they're
great but the fact that they put this
team in the middle of La that no one in
La gives a [__] about I don't know I
don't know why they did that when they
were from San dieg kep in San Diego San
Diego loved them any Chargers Rams here
too I was very confused because the Rams
has already been here from how many
years charers games are just away games
for them I mean I I I'm sure when you
went there was tons of Patriots fans
there was so much Patriots fans I was
very surprised I couldn't believe but I
it was a great it was a great game
though though you know the Chargers I
feel like they're a team that just
always comes up short you never sure
well cuz their coach is a [__] idiot
but I mean it's been happening since
like what oh the 80s actually yeah since
thls and all that I mean before th FS
we're talking D Fels Kell wins low times
they're cursed I don't know why they're
amazing offense amazing players so many
stars but they just can't finish game
yeah that's true it is rough they who
they just lose to oh the Lions yeah that
was a good game just lost the LI yeah I
didn't even know yeah yeah see yeah it
was a close game too yeah like three
points or something so um how how long
obviously you're going to get off tour
soon about halfway through how uh how
soon are you going to go back in and
make make the next album I'm already I'm
already I'm already working on it yeah
I'm already working on it I'm already
working on it I'm working on a lot of
music right now was it when's it early
next year yeah yeah I want to get that
out first quarter so you're not going to
make everybody wait half a decade Kevin
I'm not playing with him I'm not playing
with him Kev I was going to say like uh
for you like cuzz you know a span of 5
years people come and go right like
music Chang
yeah Tik Tok probably wasn't popping
like that in 2018 2019 it really
wouldn't it just started actually yeah
so it's like the whole music industry
kind of changes for you like uh you know
how do you like kind of still make
people give a [__] uh cuz once you go
away so long man fans move on they find
new people like but obviously you're
still doing your thing the tour is going
crazy but like to me it's like hard to
like be gone for 5 years per se I mean
you were dropping some [__] but like and
like still make people care like yeah I
mean it was I was hard cuz I I was even
trying to figure it out and I feel like
it's just me being naturally honest and
myself I can't do no gimmicky [__]
and feel like that's kind of you know
what I'm saying I'm just not that person
or that artist never been so I'm just
honest and that has been it's been door
opening it's been eye opening it's been
you know what I'm saying cuz they now
get to I'm letting him in I've been so
reserved I'm so closed off yeah so I
feel like cuz when I was telling you
about you know the industry and
everything I feel like it just made me
just go into my own little bubble you
know so I didn't let my even my fans in
that bubble so now that I'm letting them
in I feel like that's what I feel like
that's the only thing that they've been
missing really from me besides me
obviously dropping music right so that
connection just rebuilding that
connection you know